the bitcoin spot etf is one of the most
debated subject in all of finance right
now as we know across the world multiple
jurisdictions they've approved various
etfs and etps for the bitcoin market
within the united states last year for
the first time we got approval of a
bitcoin futures etf but there still is
no bitcoin spot etf if you're an
investor in the public markets and you
want exposure to bitcoin you don't have
very many options you could go buy that
bitcoin futures etf but it's not ideal
you could go and buy gbtc the grayscale
bitcoin trust and get that exposure but
again may not be ideal for all investors
and then ultimately you could go buy
either a bitcoin miner or something like
microstrategy that seems to track the
price of bitcoin regardless of how you
want to get the exposure the current
options aren't nearly as good as it
would be if there was a bitcoin spot etf
and so now there's a recent study that
has come out that suggests a bitcoin
spot etf wouldn't just allow people to
actually get better cleaner more ideal
exposure to bitcoin but also it could
lead to a massive influx of capital from
a variety of different market
participants we've got a tweet here from
eric valshunes from bloomberg in which
he says that the new nasdaq survey of
financial advisors finds 72 percent of
them would be more likely to invest in
crypto if a spot etf were available 86
who already have access to crypto or
have a position in crypto plan to
increase their investment and their
ideal allocation is six percent of their
portfolio those financial advisors they
control 26 trillion dollars of assets
and they're saying that they want to put
six percent of their portfolios into
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies obviously
we need a bitcoin spot etf there's a
huge regulatory obstacle in the way
whether you agree or disagree with why
the bitcoin spot etf has not been
approved yet it's very obvious that it
would give people better exposure to the
asset and that it would lead to a
massive influx of capital coming into
bitcoin my guess is that over time we
absolutely will get the bitcoin spot etf
the big question is just when will we
get it and what is the damage that's
done before it arrives hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time